[Música]
a minha avó era pianista profissional e
ela sempre teve um sonho o de ensinar um
dos metros dela tocar piano para tocar
junto com ela ela tentou com um não deu
certo
tentou com a outra também não deu aí
chegou a minha vez e ela atravessava a
cidade toda semana de trem para vir me
ensinar a tocar piano ela sentava do meu
lado e ficava a mostrando como tocar
nota por nota daquela música que ela
tanto gostava de ouvir
ela ficou fazendo escuro ano nós até
cogitamos trazer para vocês um piano
para poder tocar aquela música pra vocês
mas não deu certo por razões logísticas
então eu resolvi trazer um videozinho
pra vocês pra mostrar um pouquinho do
que eu aprendi com a minha avó
durante essas aulas de piano veja já é
isso e foi isso tudo que eu consegui
aprender com a minha avó
eu não sei se essa foi essa coisa da
frustração mas esse negócio de aprender
o aprendizado sempre mexeu muito comigo
tanto que hoje eu trabalho com
treinamentos na ensinando e ajudando
líderes lá das melhores empresas para
trabalhar eu trabalho no great place to
work
essa organização que faz o ranking das
melhores empresas para se trabalhar aqui
no brasil em vários outros países do
mundo e meu trabalho pessoal é
justamente esse conversar com
colaboradores funcionários e líderes
para demonstrar como construir essa
excelente empresa onde as pessoas querem
tem vontade de ir todos os dias mas o
desafio maior é justamente aí porque
quando eu converso com funcionários com
colaboradores
eles dizem que um great place to work ou
seja a excelente empresa para trabalhar
deveria ser mais ou menos assim um great
place to work
agora quando você vai conversar com
gestores diretores presidentes de
empresa eles mudam um pouquinho essa
ordem eles falam não tem que ser um
great place to work aumentar
carga de trabalho e o desafio e se
demonstrar que não é sobre é é é sobre
disputa na verdade é sobre parceria é
fazer entender que aquela empresa onde
atingir os melhores resultados e aquela
outra empresa que tem as pessoas mais
felizes podem e devem ser a mesma
empresa para que a gente possa ter um
equilíbrio não é
eu costumo dizer que as melhores
empresas têm esse entendimento pela raiz
tanto isso é verdade que a história da
felicidade até que a universidade
warwick um super instituição no reino
unido trouxe pra gente é algo que talvez
a gente já soubesse pessoas felizes são
13 por cento mais produtivas do que
pessoas infelizes
uau né sem novidades mas eu percebo que
mesmo que não há uma novidade quando não
é uma cueca no e já que é uma coisa tão
óbvia é legal ver o óbvio testado e
aprovado às vezes sabe algumas pessoas
dizem ah mas é só 13% daquele ou daquela
pessoa mas se você juntar num cômputo
geral a cultura daquela empresa pode se
tornar uma verdadeira o verdadeiro
diferencial competitivo isso é muito
bacana
as melhores empresas para trabalhar
entender uma coisa ela chega nos
melhores resultados por meio das pessoas
e não apesar das pessoas como pessoas
está no centro daquilo que eu faço a eu
imaginava que tecnologia não fosse muito
o assunto pra mim é mais é curioso
porque a tecnologia tem atribuições que
a gente nem imagina é porque quando a
gente pensa no tradicional aí uber que
veio mudando o mundo dos taxistas ou
quando você pensa na netflix ou mudou
totalmente acabou na verdade com vida
das videolocadoras blockbusters são
exemplos mais comuns mais corriqueiras a
gente entende melhor mas você já parou
para pensar que talvez a tecnologia está
falindo o ramo de campainhas pois é
ninguém mais usa campanha hoje em dia na
verdade você chega na casa da pessoa e
mandou a mensagem escrito cheguei e
pronto a campanha está sendo mais
utilizada e eu não sei se eu acabei me
sentindo um pouco
o taxista quando o bayern chegou mas eu
confesso para vocês
e quando eu percebi que meu mundo estava
se tornando cada vez mais tecnológico
mais digital
a minha reação pessoal foi justamente
contrária
eu quis fazer com que tudo fosse mais
humano possível
é curioso porque quando as pessoas vão
para o trabalho de manhã cedo elas
acabam levando o seu lado o engenheiro
do trabalho elas levam seu lado o
analista de dados há o lado consultora
de marketing mas eu acredito que elas
deveriam mesmo levar o seu lado humano
então ao invés de pensar em tudo que é
dado tudo que é byte tudo que a tec
eu comecei a pensar em tudo que é toc e
pensei 'onde que poderia ser esse espaço
esse lugar onde tudo sobre toque é sobre
gente sobre emoção sobre encantamento
foi assim que nós desenvolvemos um
programa de liderança em um lugar mágico
na disney a em parceria com o ibex
instituto com grande alexandre livre o
qual eu virei fã
isso se tornou uma ideia maravilhosa
claro que eu fui pra disney de graça não
estou pensando no ano que vem a gente
conduziu um treinamento de liderança nas
praias da tailândia quem sabe pega
remover o fato é que nós estamos lá com
a mochila nas costas com um uniforme
completo camiseta do great place to work
a eles entregam pra gente uma pulseira
superlegal tecnológica em que quando
você quer entrar numa atração você põe
em costa e você entra na oração você
quer pagar alguma coisa que você compra
na loja você cliente gosta e já pagou
fez a transação financeira achei
superlegal aquela pulseira da disney né
e lá fomos de repente eles fizeram um
exercício tão bacana um exercício de
treinamento foi eu quero que vocês
repararem se vocês vão encontrar ao
redor do parque lixo espalhado pelo chão
ea gente foi com esse olho clínico né
e começamos a olhar um lado olhar para o
outro e de fato a gente viu que o parque
estava extremamente limpo
por mais que tivessem milhares de
pessoas rondando naquele parte no final
do dia eles explicaram pra gente porque
o porquê eles falaram pessoal e isso não
se dá por acaso isso aconteceu porque
décadas atrás o senhor o ao disney dono
do negócio todo estava andando pelo
parque
dele e ficava muito chateado quando via
que alguém jogava um lixo no chão e ele
pensou e ficou tão triste e um dia ele
conversou com seus funcionários ele
falou pessoal
eu tive uma idéia eu quero que vocês
amanhã tirem todas as latas de lixo do
nosso parque
como assim os funcionários olharam para
a cara do outro e não fazia sentido
nenhum aquela ideia do ao disney mas
aqueles funcionários tinham o que né
gente
o boleto e boleto faz a gente se mover
eles obedeceram ao disney tiraram todas
as latas de lixo naquele dia
o dia seguinte foi um verdadeiro carros
claro as pessoas jogavam lixo onde
achava que tinha que jogar não tinha
lixeira quando elas foram embora do
parque naquela noite
o audi nem ficou no parque e ficou
andando pra lá e pra cá sozinho
de um lado para o outro os funcionários
olharem pensaram que aquele velho está
fazendo quando ele volta
ele fala para os funcionários olha eu
percebi que o acúmulo de lixo fica mais
ou menos 30 passos de distância um dos
outros então amanhã eu quero que vocês
devolvam as latas de lixo para o nosso
parque porém coloquem elas a 30 passos
de distância uma das outras e o problema
foi resolvido até hoje qual uma ideia
simples de grande efeito e quando
comecei a pensar nisso eu olhei mais uma
vez meu pulso e vi aquela pulseira essa
pulseira que aqueles entrega pra gente e
aí eu pensei será que essa pulseira faz
há algo a mais a não ser você poder
entrar numa atração ou pagar algo na
loja na lanchonete e fui perguntar para
o pessoal da disney e quando eu
perguntei eles falaram ah você me pegou
de fato isso serve para alguma coisa
além disso ela serve pra que você a
gente possa identificar onde as pessoas
estão no parque porque elas emitem um
sinal
elas emitiram um sinal a gente sabe qual
o banheiro que foi mais utilizado desde
um retoque de limpeza a qual lanchonete
foi mais utilizada e precisa de um
retoque de alimentos que eu fiquei
pensando gente
no fim das contas essa pulseira ip
tecnológica não está fazendo nada de tão
diferente
que o o disney fez décadas atrás
ela estava ajudando a cuidar das pessoas
e falando em pessoas uma história que eu
nunca mais vou esquecer foi contada por
nós esse curso a história da dona rose
que foi uma senhora que trabalhou 55
anos na disney
ela ficou 55 anos fazendo a mesma coisa
não muda o mundo não mudou de posição
ela ficava na portaria dos parques
recepcionando as pessoas que estavam
vindo conhecer e o dia quando ela estava
em vias de se aposentar perguntaram dona
rose
a senhora nunca teve vontade de
trabalhar em outro departamento em outra
área do nosso parque ela disse nunca
tive essa vontade e aí perguntaram mas
porque dona rose e ela respondeu porque
se eu fosse trabalhar em uma outra área
do parque eu perderia a oportunidade de
dar o primeiro sorriso para as pessoas
que estão vindo aqui conheci a gente
eles têm uma pulseira tecnológica que
consegue sozinha preencher um dashboard
mas eles jamais cogitaram trocar a dona
rose por uma catraca
a tecnologia é inevitável
ela vai estar presente em cada vez mais
empresas em cada vez mais departamentos
e em cada vez mais posições de trabalho
disso eu não tenho dúvida mas aqui tem
um recorte que poucas pessoas falam pra
gente quando fala desse tema da
tecnologia que é o tempo
eu acredito que só dura a tecnologia que
vai nos ajudar a cuidar das pessoas e
com essa idéia de pessoas e tecnologia
eu voltei para o brasil super
entusiasmado e fui perguntar pra nossa
equipe de tecnologia que estava
introduzindo uma nova fórmula de
algoritmo e quando vi que esse negócio
de algoritmo estava sendo introduzido eu
fiquei totalmente incomodado eu falei
que é isso e porque quando você pergunta
geralmente o que é um algoritmo as
pessoas falam algoritmo é algo ritmo e
fica por isso mesmo
mas eu tive interesse em conhecer eu
quis entender melhor e percebi que o
algoritmo era de fato a chave que nós
poderíamos usar nos
btw pra entender mais as pessoas a ir
mais a fundo nos dados saber quais eram
seus anseios e desejos o que elas
esperam em uma excelente empresa para
trabalhar e só assim nós teríamos uma
chance ainda maior de construir uma
sociedade melhor
eu sei que as empresas hoje querem fazer
tudo high tech alta tecnologia mas eu
acho que a verdadeira revolução é fazer
tudo ray toque
a gente sabe que está vivenciando a
plena era da tecnologia mas eu proponho
que a gente comece a prestar atenção
numa nova era que está chegando à era da
tecnologia a a aérea em que a gente
percebe que a tecnologia está aí e não
apenas para mudar processos mas sim para
transformar a vida das pessoas e com
isso eu fiquei pensando qual poderia ser
minha última história pra contar aqui
pra vocês que conecta tecnologia com
tecnologia e eu pensei em contar uma
história de uma pessoa que eu amo muito
muito próxima de mim mas que não está
mais aqui entre nós a história da minha
pianista favorita a minha avó ela já
estava bem doente tinha no hospital
praticamente desligados sabe e eu ia
visitá ela toda semana assim como a
fazer comigo antes para me ensinar a
tocar piano e olhei pra ela um dia
fiquei pensando puxa eu soubesse tocar
aquela música no piano que ela gostava
de ouvir
aí olhei ao redor e obviamente é um
hospital e nem piano eu tinha ali né
eu não tinha piano mas eu tinha spotify
e aí eu fiquei pensando será que eu
encontro àquela música e procurei
procurei e achei aquela música e não
tive dúvida
coloquei pra tocar pra minha volta vi
quando ela começou a ouvir aquela música
do nada ela levantou os bracinhos e
começa a brilhar um piano no ar quando
vi aquela cena eu ia me emocionar
ela tava pela última vez tocando uma
música pra mim eu sei que tem muita
gente com medo da inteligência
artificial das máquinas mas eu proponho
que se for pra ter medo que não seja da
inteligência artificial das máquinas mas
sim da ignorância das pessoas
eu sei que tem muita gente com medo de
perder o emprego mas o medo real deveria
ser de viver uma vida sem propósito
nenhum
também sei que o contrário tem muita
gente empolgada feliz com todas as
possibilidades da tecnologia e eu também
acho o máximo
mas eu acho que as verdadeiras
possibilidades que a gente tem que se
empolgará redação das folhas
possibilidades humanas
eu não aprendi a tocar piano com a minha
avó mas uma coisa ela me ensinou que o
tempo organiza tudo e que não são as
conexões digitais são só as conexões
humanas que duram para sempre
obrigado
[Música]